all right some of the best recipes come
from the internet if you're hungry I've
saved a delicious story just for you
this is what I'm
liking if you love pickles like I do you
need to check out a Pennsylvania woman's
Tik Tok Channel she shares her most
unique recipes to Millions there's
jalapeno Mustard Pickles yummy Buffalo
Ranch pickles awesome she even created a
pumpkin spice pickles for the holidays
suspicious but I'm willing to try it
let's get her in here say hi to is
watching on
wou
hi hi so how did you learn I love
pickles by the way so I love everything
you're a part of um I've never tried the
Pumpkin Spice or whatever that last one
was but I'm willing to try it how did
you get into it so my curiosity for
pickling started at a or for con for
making concoctions started at a very
young age I was one of those kids that
made potions under my bed um and a
couple years ago my mom and I were
making burgers on the grill and her her
thing was you can never have a burger
without a pickle and we didn't have any
pickles and so she introduced me to
quickling or quick pickling and so I
watched her throw together some thinly
sliced cucumber vinegar salt sugar some
spices and within an hour we had
delicious little pickles to put on our
burgers and needless to say I haven't
stopped experimenting ever since um I've
been making all kinds of pickle
concoctions some of them are good some
of them are not so good one time I made
pot roast pickles and it was a complete
fail um but one time I made a pickled
peaches with like a brown butter or
brown sugar concoction and they were
delicious so you never know what you're
going to get and I just love
experimenting with the pickle
concoctions oh my gosh my mouth is
watering like my mouth like it has not
stopped watering I love you so much that
all sounds so delicious that peach
number what thank you so much is I'm
liking your right now right oh thank you
that's not all though our season long
partner pilot pin makers of G2 the go-to
pin at the Kelly Clarkson show loves
creative Foodies just like you ma'am so
they're going to be riding you a check
for $1,000 how's that
sound I'm kid thank you I also love your
nail game that was those your nails are
awesome they're blue on oh girl these
are tape on look at us one CVS Trip Away
there you go thanks to all our guests
this hour Sarah villis pinky Cole Magnus
Eric and lawence a in y'all have a great
day and if it's not try and change
[Music]
[Applause]
it thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home